- So President Trump is
now former president Trump
and Joe Biden is now the current President
of the United States.
And as many have pointed out
that means that Donald Trump
is now a private citizen.
So to whatever extent
that president Trump had
immunity as president,
that no longer applies.
And as a private citizen,
Trump can now be sued
and investigated for all
of the things that he
may or may not have done.
And there were a lot
of open questions as President.
Can a sitting president be indicted?
Can they be investigated?
Can they apply executive
privilege whenever they want?
And you'd think as a private citizen
a lot of those questions
would be answered.
But the truth is there are a
lot of open questions still.
If and when former President
Trump is investigated,
he will claim some sort
of residual immunity.
And these are still questions
that will have to be litigated
and answered by the courts
for any of these
investigations to go forward.
Because this wasn't a normal presidency
and he wasn't a normal president.
So stay tuned for more
presidential legal news.
And as always,
I'll see you in court.